[Music]
welcome back to careful Boys in this
episode we have a very special
announcement yeah Nick Dunn is
officially black
belt dude that's a lifelong ACH I want
to cry dude I want to
cry aome aw
awesome so for those of you guys who
don't know and almost every other
martial art black belt is for [__]
[__] and BJJ which is the black belt
that Nick has slow job Jitsu it's the
average time to get one is like 7 to 10
years and and Nick got it in
20 and it's SO3 it's so highly regarded
that they don't call them Sensei they
call them professors so like he's a
professor of the sport we acely say
don't call us that he's not a teacher
he's a professor professor does sound
kind these kind of
professors yeah I have a bunch of beers
in my house dude that's so good huge
it's a huge [__] achievement as hard
is there a test or they just throw it at
you dude they kind of well I wasn't
expecting anything like cuz we were
going to promote some of the blue belts
and some of the other white belts in the
academy and everyone got promoted
together not yeah a couple people got
promoted not everyone gets promoted it's
people yeah we just gave them away just
and then we we get we we get paid out
for everyt we give out we get money no
but you know some people didn't get uh
promoted it's the people that that uh we
think deserve promotions do you think
they feel left out yeah sometimes but
that's kind of the point though you
should feel a little left out you should
be like yeah you should train harder
[__] um but
um yeah it was so it was completely
unexpected what we usually do is like if
you're going to get to a new belt we
have a couple blue belts that have been
blue belts for a long time and they're
going to Purple belt so we'll do like
Shark Tank rounds so it'll be like we
had a potluck over there so the first
half of the potluck is everybody
training and then we'll do the guys who
are getting promoted they all stay on
their back and they they just roll with
the whole Academy and they do it for
like 40 what a potluck is huh so that's
the first half of the potluck okay like
when you actually eat the first half
everybody's
training after the training so pretty
much you get attacked by like 20 people
so then he was naming everybody out and
it was all the purple all the blue belts
going to Purple belt that we all
expected and then he called me um my
buddy Kenny who's another coach there
and my other buddy Hinrich who's a coach
at fight Academy so he still fights over
there but he trains Jitsu with us and we
all started together in like 2010 that's
why we all started doing MMA together
started together yeah yeah you started
ji- Jitsu in 2010 we started doing MMA
like kickboxing in 2010 and then we
didn't start doing the ghe until like
2015 2016 wow so uh anyway so we all so
he made us all go down too and I was
like [__] I was like I didn't want to I
wasn't even expecting to do shark tank
rounds or anything I was just going to
[__] around you know it's a different
yeah I was like [__] dude we got to roll
with everybody and um so we were rolling
with everybody for like 45 minutes and
then we do the
promotions and then my buddy Hinrich so
we do an order so everyone gets Stripes
first so the stripes on the Belt meaning
like progress whatever and then we get
did the white belts to Blue belts we had
like a 17-year-old that that went to a
blue belt won a bunch of tournaments
he's a beast and then we did the purple
belts uh the blue belts the purple belts
and we did all those guys and then next
up was like we didn't have any people
being promoted it's a brown belt so the
first one coach pulled out a black belt
oh [__] like oh [__] and I knew cuz I I
I had an idea was my buddy hinr like so
how many belts did he have in his hiding
in his ghee dude we have a little bag no
honestly it's like a little grabag it's
a trench code yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
nobody's getting promoted to it don't
you worry but cuz usually people have to
do that like they put in their GE or
like they try to be sneaky with it he
has to carry every color so no one can
predict yeah exactly EXA so when you saw
the black belt you knew it was for you I
thought it was for my buddy I I thought
it was for my buddy Hinrich and I was
like oh dude hinrich's going this
[__] black crazy such a Monumental
and he calls out Hinrich to come up and
uh dude I started like tearing up I'm
like oh [__] I'm getting hyped like cuz
everyone's so hyped for your homie yeah
cuz that's you know we all started
together he was like you know so he got
his black belt and then I got mine right
after and he called me to go up and I
was like what the [__] I was tripping
out you're deflecting I was I said are
you sure about that that's the first
thing I said I like you sure you sure
you sure I deserve this wow and then the
last one was my uh my other buddy uh
Kenny so all three of us got our black
belts together and we all started
training with Joe in 2017 27 Joe's our
current Jitsu coach now but I always
talk about him he's so special for us
because we were doing some bull [__]
before we trained with him like we were
the [__] Stone ages of the Jiu-Jitsu
before he came and um when he was
showing us like actually how to train
and how to put everything together we
were like oh [__] this guy is completely
different from all the other black belts
that we trained with in the past so um
and we've been with him ever since and
we put on does this feel what do you
feel when he put
on not you it's so [__] corny but
that's tight you look at it and you go
holy [__] like it's a it's a trip like
you look at it for so long cuz I wasn't
expecting that um did you like jack off
in it afterwards I I [__] you look in
the mirror at home no I didn't I didn't
do that but like when I look at I would
when I look at
pictures I go what the [__] like it's a
trip like it just
all my G would have been white if I had
a blackt I would have thrown my other
color cuz I wanted to [__] stand out
like bam big dude it's like it's like
getting married or like getting a PhD
it's like it's something that when you
start something you know what the end is
right and every promotion you get you're
still not there but you know what it is
at the end B it's not the end that's
such a norming take dude hey thank you
Steve Jesus dude it's about the journey
bud no but you know it's funny that you
say that cuz like the first thing my
coach said was like look like it's so
corny but it's so true it's like when I
got my black belt is when I realized
like I don't know [__] that's what he
said and you do feel they always say
that no but it's true though it's true
like you but it's true like cuz you do
have to start everything all over again
cuz you have to look at the game it's
like a it's like a bachelor's degree if
they said when you get your black you
don't know [__] then let me kick your
ass right now then I'm a white Bel I
really don't know [__] now but there's
some black belts out there that just
aren't like not worthy but like there's
like there's like you know lowle black
belts you know so how many levels is
there from the black belt and then I be
seeing like red belts and [__] yeah
that's like a coral belt I think those
guys are like [__] you have to be
like you have to be trained for like 50
years or some [__] 50 years all right so
cuz even black belt yeah or coral Coral
black belt to the the first stripe you
have to be a black belt for even just
five years I think like two or three two
or three so it's like every degree on
your black how many degrees do you get I
got no degrees no how many can you in in
your juj sta I think for each belt you
get like four stripes and then typically
you go to the next belt if it's kids
dude you're getting one for like courage
one for [__] honor one for being I
want to join the kids class because it's
like you got to keep feeding the the dop
there nothing you can do to like mess up
and then they demote you back to
Brown technically no technically but
like not even if you kill somebody no I
think you might
get cuz Brazilians are crazy what if
you're just touching somebody in a funny
way a funny way that you get another
black belt dude like that's it's like
the Catholic Church you just open a
school somewhere else lowkey jokes but
like kind of that's how somebody these
guys op no the good thing about our JY
is like we just have to not do any of
that stuff and then people will come
train with us yeah cuz then they'll go
all all the other scumbag gy for real
like everyone like every other gym is a
little creepy they're a little culty
they're a little like funny all we have
to do is just be nice to everybody
crimes yeah for some like it's funny cuz
we had a bunch of new uh members from a
different gym mhm and some of white
belts and they come in and they're just
very like scared and stuff and then
we're like yo what's up dude and they're
like oh hi you know and you could tell
they like that because everywhere they
go they L are literally treated like
[__] just because they're white belts
dude yeah and it's like dude what the
[__] is this white white belts like
don't exist what is it what is that term
when you're like pledging for a like a
fraternity a like a ple and in some more
traditional Jiu-Jitsu gims you got to
clean the mats you you don't you don't
talk to me for go talk to the blue belt
if you have any questions like don't
even talk to me no bro like some black
BS are like that like some new customers
will come through the door and they just
will be like they won't even like kind
of give them the time of day is your
belt transferable if you were to go to
like a Kung Fu place and you're like oh
I already have this can I they'll be
like you don't know Crane style so take
that [__] off what's What's the culture
like though like so now that you're a
black belt if you like roll up to
another like Jiu-Jitsu Studio or
whatever like you go to Vegas or
something like that and because you're a
black belt you walk in do the other
black belts have to like test you and
[__] kind of like I have a Target like
the board and then you like break their
board and [__] like that like they'll
try to [__] kind of kill me you know
what I mean cuz they all want to see
they all want to see what's up rep your
school right everyone everyone's curious
yeah you walk right in like with your
black belt on and walk on top of their
logo I step on it and I start digging my
rubbing my feet on it slowly taking off
your [__] so you just want to go
train cuz you're like in Austria or
whatever everyone does that yeah do they
know that you're a black belt um if you
show up on ghe day if it's like yeah
dude it's the same [__] as me walking in
with my purple belt from June R karate
nobody's going to [__] know who I am
it's like there's a barcode on the
[__] would you ever like go to a spot
and like just you know bust out your old
blue belt just wear it even though you
know you're a black belt just be like
people that's frowned upon in the
community like people will get mad at
you for that so you'll get an extra Bel
but like you know like in Jutsu like
YouTube content like that'll be a prank
like a black belt wears a blue belt and
he enters a random gy Spiderman costume
it goes the hood yeah yeah Kyrie Irving
just dresses like an old guy and and
they'll have like Boll of like other
guys rolling with them saying like oh
you're not you're no way you're a blue
belt you know they say some [__] like
that you're really good for a white belt
why'd you do that and he's like he has
no idea like that's what they'll do
that's the whole the one I don't get
about those is why did he dress up as
Spider-Man it's like nobody wants to
play Spider-Man in basketball like that
one doesn't make sense
to it hides all his identifying features
perfectly yeah I mean the way I found
out was Mike song texted me he's like
Nick got his black belt today I was like
what the [__] yeah Mike was there man
get a my boy Mike a stripe I think he
did actually oh yeah Mike's getting good
bro I thought he hasn't been training
that's he he came back he he was out cuz
he had a neck injury and he had Batman
neck so he could like turn his head dang
that [__] sucks bro from dancing no from
jiujitsu jiujitsu [__] you up dude yeah
especially if you're not like training
those neck muscles I thought he was
doing PES or some [__] that's that hurts
now now that you have your black belt
what's your next like goal are you going
to do a tournament are you going to do
any fight yeah I plan on competing but
right now it's just like we we have we
actually got a bunch of new black belts
coming to the gym from like other gyms
in our area so like we've been training
with those guys and it's been really
cool do you sometimes punch
them good question test them like real
lightly no no no no we try to be on our
best behavior this is why Joe's not a
black belt by the
way do your knives ever fall out
never got a black belt in karate I never
got a black belt in my life ever that's
standard for most
people but yeah it was it was a trip I
could [__] up hella black belts though
they're [__] weak
dude in a in a unfair Advantage but did
you go to karate school or anything I
did a couple of stuff what's the highest
you
got um well the last one I think I had
three strip well it was like they didn't
have the belt system they just have
white brown black they should have gave
him his brown though me and St at that
one that was a [__] scam dud [__]
he was better than everybody there
better than everyone there everyone
there I'm not just saying that either
cuz I would love to clown on him and say
he wasn't but he was better than
everyone else was half ass in their
[__] forms and [__] and then I'm like
man give this [__] a brown belt
but I think we're we're being too loud
we're going to embarrass Joe yeah we
were yelling it too we were like you
give this [__] brown belt right now
get a brown belt but then because you
guys are obnoxious they're like no they
must teach him a lesson I want to talk
to [__] man
who's [__] this guy's not keying
hard
enough so speaking of brown belts like
can we take your brown belt and like
hang it up in the office now yeah if you
want that's one of the only belts I have
still I sto my brown belt I think I
stopped my you lost the other ones I
lost my blue belt I lost my white belt
are they just meaningless to you is that
why in the middle of a roll you're just
like where the [__] did it go oh or did
you give it to people no I didn't give
it to people cuz that's a tradition too
like you pass it on to the next person
so they can put put yours on oh [__]
that's tight start he like are you white
is it white blue purple black or brown
brown black yeah barash is hella
dramatic kung fu movies
[Laughter]
dude part one's the ceremonies it's a
[__] blue
belt like is it underground in the cave
there's [__] torches
everywhere you got to go on a quest to
get your blue belt you used blue belt
though when the black belt is so used up
that it starts to get all [__] up and
you can see the white
yeah would you get pissed if we spilled
peroxide on it when you like brought it
no you bleached it my tie eyeb the
knowledge is leaving my brain it's all
leaving my brain I'm forgetting it all
but also the Jiu-Jitsu belts look a
little different from the karate belts
yeah cuz the karate belts are like
[__] thick and it's made for they're
starched so it's made for performance
right so then like when you're doing
karate it's like and then like did
Jujitsu ones like you don't want it
[__] dangling like a Cholo's belt you
know so you you want to have it short so
you can't pull that during a oh you can
there's guards with it that you can can
you like switch it with like take
someone's plat put it on that like they
go like this and they'll [__] tie it
around you and [__] like there's a way
there's a guard that we like to play
where it's like it's usually they it's
like lapel guard where you pull
someone's lapel and you pull it like
this so they can't like move but you
could do with a belt like you like sit
up guard with it I don't think I've ever
seen that's that's pretty cool have you
ever seen those videos of like I like to
watch how stuff's made and they have the
videos of them making black belts in
those factories and they're just like
conveyor belts of [__] black bels
just like going off the line and getting
put into big packages right and shipped
in huge containers and [__] Bart's like
wait they don't have somebody hand
sewing them from like the temples and
[__] B news no they they ship they ship
180,000 a
week they're [__] giv them away yeah
they're [__] clear plastic containers
not floating monks in Tibet that are
just [__] putting Masters getting
[__] squid ink and D in every single
one
of they produce an episode on just black
belt how is easiest things to produce
easier than any other they're almost
meaningless some producer like got his
ass beat and he's just like pissed it's
way more difficult to make white cuz you
have to D it yeah it's really really
it's a longer
process there are people that like give
themselves a black belt though what can
we do what can we do in the office to
commemorate your Martial Arts Journey
like some kind of DEC that like
symbolizes it we have nothing that
really I an old ghee or you got
like wax figure of his ear a giant wax
figure of his ear kind tyon ear
candy we should have a quality versus
quantity competition so like he's got a
quality black belt and then I'll go out
and I'll collect hella black belts from
like taekwondo Studios that that will
give it to me in one
year so I'll be like I got this from
this I I do have a second degreee black
Bel T do that [__] you just pay for it
that's lit though you pay for it you
don't even have to show up you could pay
them how much money do you think you
invested to the point where you got your
second black dude so much cuz I was like
what like 11 when I got it or some
[__] damn dude you were a little
killer you were a master at 11 I was
like really good when I was young bro
you don't got no videos myology dude I
want no legit bro you know what I mean
honestly if it wasn't for Tech I don't
think I'd be like good at like dancing
the coordination that's cuz it is
dancing dude I swear to God there's so
many forms it's like Jesus Christ some
of the best tumers are I did I I thought
it was just [__] dancing and I I I
had to quit I used to hate doing I used
to hate doing forms that was the worst
part of like karate or Tao I used to
hate it I be like I want to do this so
there you never have done like Jiu-Jitsu
forms there's no Jiu-Jitsu forms I don't
think you want to get first yeah
yeah I have an
idea I have an idea for a jkid adventure
we'll go to lionhart and then we sh tank
you all right we do that so all of us
all of us we get weapons what shark tank
so we roll with him but then he has to
take on like us five but one at a time
and then we could see his black belt
expert get demonstrated yeah four two or
3 one B's talking about it like he's
just so so talented by
[Laughter]
cry you know what was surprising though
a lot of people like cuz in my head like
okay having a black belt is cool like it
a tight you know there's something that
I was working towards or just like
working like I got as a result of trans
you know um but then all these random
people that I just didn't think would
ever give a [__] about it at all were
like congratulations like
congratulations and I was like well
everyone knows a black belt's a big
thing man that's like why would you
think I don't care about college but
when people graduate I tell them
congratulations yeah but like you know
but it's different when people say to
you on Instagram when they like text you
and then like they call
like dude like congrats people that I
didn't know were even into martial arts
at all or like even knew what a [__]
juu black belt was you know what I mean
cuz like sometimes it doesn't track with
certain people I think the culture is
more mainstream now because even in the
UFC there's like high level Fighters
that don't have their black belt and
then like let's say they win the fight
and then their coach comes in the cage
and then puts their new belt on their
neck and you see them being emotional
like they almost didn't even care they W
the fight they don't care they just made
like half a million dollars they cared
that their coach gave him the belt
they're like oh [__] that's [__]
crazy do you think he has like a brown
belt and a black belt and then if he
loses the fight he puts a brown Bel [__]
or he just tucks it away like not this
one not this one and he still gets a
black belt yeah TI if the dude who like
harassed you on the street says congrats
hey man I heard you got your black
Bel you know the cop who gave you the
jaywalking ticket says congrats he giv
me a hug major accomplishment because
they don't make jiujitsu black belts
like oh they do make them in a factory
but they don't make it easy they don't
make it easy at
all 180,000 we just roll them
[Music]
out got you man these are going fast was
there was there it's the same taekwan do
black belt that they use too same one
it's all the same other than like your
coach was there like somebody in
particular that you know like it made
made you feel a lot that that they
witnessed you or like congratulated you
on getting this some that you either
like pety needed to prove yourself to oh
not really not really it was really cool
to get it with my boys like that was
[__] that's the sick man like cuz to
think about where we started from and
how we got into this whole [__] game
like is and it's they were all like
dedicated up to stick with it that whole
time because like even some of the guys
from the Pod that we all train with like
some of them who were kind of supposed
to get their black belt before us like
they still kind of fell off too you know
did you have a period where you took a
break at all like here and there like I
think inconsistency was probably more of
issue than anything like especially on
like purple belt days and I'll be back I
just took a year break but I'll be back
yeah like just on and off I thought I
was going to leave the video right now
like where you going you going dude but
uh once again it was it was really
important like it just meant more that I
got it from my coach who thought that we
were ready for it cuz he he definitely
like holds us back and [__] um which I'm
glad he did because it's like cuz you
were probably ready but he's all like no
not yet yeah maybe but it's like it's
like it's such a mindset shift too it's
like that's the other thing I'm glad
that you got it there yeah for sure did
you ever feel like you're only giving it
to me cuz you you gave it to them you
don't want me to feel left out yeah a
little bit yeah little bit but did you
go home that night and smash smash what
never mind dude you know what you need
to do n no way dude just be naked
nothing but black belt and you go ha and
then you make your dick
bow I thought that was going to be
something crude but it turned out to be
really
honorable cuz there's torches everywhere
yeah it's torches and he's just butt ass
naked he goes
div
professor and then the dick bows ha all
right give it up for Professor Nick dun
professor you got to wear Spider-Man
outfit you go play
basketball